nous poursuivons cette édition spéciale
résultats des élections départementales
en bourgogne sur france 3 avec elle a
besoin pour les résultats dans les
quatre départements pour les analyser et
interroger nos invités lilian melet avec
nous ainsi que eric sicaud les invités
précisément françois patriat bonjour
prénom socialiste de la région bourgogne
pour l'ump
emmanuelle coint bonjour à l'uir d'un
canton de brazey-en-plaine et puis
céline maglica bonjour jour et lieu
socialiste à dijon dans le canton de
dijon 6 nous rejoindrons tout à l'heure
en direct du creusot frédéric brochot
nouvel élu ump à autun et puis fabien
bazin est lui à corbigny nous attend lui
à nevers commençons par la saône et
loire avec une illustration de cette
bascule à droite du département le
canton de louhans c'est celui de rémy
chanteront le président socialiste
sortant battu sévèrement par mathilde de
chalumeau et anthony vadot le maire de
branche
damien routier et romy hodzic les ont
retrouvés ce matin à l'heure du marché
forcément un lendemain d'élection sur un
marché on ne parle que des résultats
surtout à louhans car outre le fait que
le département a basculé à droite et
rémi chaintron le président socialiste
sortant du conseil général était battu
sur son propre canton
ici ça ne surprend non pas du tout c'est
tout à fait
normal compte tenu de des exactions du
gouvernement actuel pas s'étonner non ça
ne se reprend pas bon fallait que ça
change
ce normal suite logique alors forcément
du côté du binôme l'ump qui a remporté
le canton le marché ce matin un petit
goût particulier il savoure surtout
qu'il s'impose avec 66 30 % des
suffrages soit deux mille six cent
quarante voix d'écart on ne pensait pas
que l'écart serait aussi important et
c'est vrai que bon on s'en réjouit on a
fait une campagne de terrain de
proximité je pense que ça a payé une
large victoire donc pour la droite
la suite logique d'une implantation
politique réussie petit retour en
arrière en 2008 anthony vadot vient de
prendre la mairie de branges
il est alors l'un des plus jeunes maires
de france et la fiche très ses ambitions
sept ans plus tard pari réussi il accède
au conseil départemental mais il va
devoir faire les choses déjà je continue
activités de merde branges et représente
la communauté de communes coeur de
bresse
j'ai deux trois autres casquettes
intercommunal pour lesquels on va
s'arranger assez vite et là on travaille
déjà la mise en place des nouvelles
instances dirigeantes au niveau du
département
une vice présidence les choses encore
pour discuter sur cet angle là
rendez vous donc jeudi à mâcon pour
l'élection du nouveau président et des
vice-présidents et ce précédent devrait
être toute logique andré accary nouvel
homme fort du département de
saône-et-loire leader de l'opposition
ump confirmé hier sur france 3 sa
candidature à la présidence son binôme
vous le voyez s'est largement imposé
dans le canton de paray-le-monial où
étaient stéphane robert et gabriel
talent
oui
à tournus j'allais oublier andré accary
est arrivé très tôt pour assister au
dépouillement
très rapidement il s'est isolé dans un
coin de la salle pour recueillir les
informations qui lui remonte des
différents cantons et peu avant 20
heures la tendance est à la bascule du
conseil départemental à droite le leader
de l'opposition se veut encore prudent
j'attends déjà la confirmation
effectivement pour savoir s'il faisait
partie le département bascule
effectivement la tendance nous fait dire
que le rassemblement serait 16 13 voilà
donc après effectivement je pense que
c'est le fruit d'un travail constant si
d'une préparation des élections qui dure
depuis des mois
et puis il faut le reconnaître aussi un
mécontentement vis-à-vis de l'actuelle
majorité
il est maintenant 20h past et jean marc
nesme le maire de paray le monial vient
de déclarer le nom du vainqueur sur le
canton
sans surprise andré accary est élu avec
plus de 67% des voix face au binôme
socialiste la bascule
ajoutez à cette victoire le triomphe est
total mais modeste c'est quelque part
aussi une reconnaissance donc je suis
très heureux de ce score avec carole
j'aimerais bien qu'elle soit là mais
effectivement on est tout à fait
satisfaite
résultat après un moment d'échangé avec
ses soutiens andré accary s'est rendu en
préfecture de mâcon le troisième tour et
maintenant à l'ordre du jour le
conseiller départemental réélu fait
figure de favori à la présidence les
prochains jours seront cruciaux dans
cette course au perchoir pour la saône
et loire elle a besoin l'événement c'est
donc la bascule de la gauche vers la
droite et après 11 ans de présidence
socialiste une page se tourne la gauche
n'a remporté que 13 cantons contre 16 à
droite les trois cantons qui la font
perdre et bien ce sont aux roues sur
saône où le duo de droite s'impose avec
seulement 30 voix d'écart montceau les
mines où la gauche est balayée comme aux
municipales il ya un an et enfin au thym
1 où là c'est une division de la gauche
qui l'a conduit à sa perte
autre symbole de cette cinglante défaite
chalon 3 et chalon 2e des cantons la
droite s'impose et même dans le cas de
chalon de très larges
la gauche qui résiste quand même en
saône-et-loire puisqu'elle remporté six
des huits triangulaire où elle était
engagée
symbole de cette résistance en bresse le
canton de cuiseaux le socialiste
frédéric cannard est réélu autre exemple
uriner en ballottage défavorable la
semaine dernière le tandem de gauche a
réussi à gagner son duel face à la
droite merci elsa et nous prenons la
direction du creusot où nous attend
frédéric brochot vainqueur pour l'ump
sur le canton au thym 1
vaujour frédéric brochot vous partagez
cette double analyse le double effet au
thym 1 sanction du gouvernement et puis
les divisions à gauche
elles vous ont bien aidé la division oui
un certes certes une division mais il ya
quand même un rejet de la politique qui
a été menée sur le département est
également la politique qui a été menée
par le conseiller général sortant est
qui et qui était absent donc voilà les
gens voulaient de la proximité les
personnes tous nos électeurs voulaient
de la proximité c'est ce que l'on a fait
durant notre campagne c'est ce que l'on
fait au quotidien sur par rapport à
notre travail on est au contact des gens
avec avec mamad mot binôme catherine
amyot voilà tout tout était réuni et les
personnes les personnes nous ont fait
confiance
mais au 1er tour vous étiez au coude à
coude 1 avec finalement les deux binômes
de gauche qui étaient donc divisé qu'est
ce qui a fait qu'il ya eu cette
amplification en votre faveur au second
tour selon lou l'amplification déjà on
était quand même pas au coude à coude
irait quand même un certain nombre de
devoirs qui nous qui nous séparait quand
même
et voilà on a fait tomber je dirais un
bastion de la gauche
les gens se reconnaissait plus par
rapport à la politique qui est menée
aujourd'hui qu'ils étaient mené jusqu'à
présent et voulait comment comme on l'a
fait du renouveau et une nouvelle
énergie
on va attendre jeudi l'élection du
président avec andré accary vous faites
partie de ceux qui espérait monter en
grade on va dire obtenir une
vice-présidence par exemple on sait que
vous êtes très investi dans le monde
agricole par exemple avec mon show très
investi dans le monde agricole déjà de
par mon métier
de par mes responsabilités également que
j'ai jusqu'à présent au sein du
département et au point au local
également après voilà on travaille avec
arrêt qu'andré j'ai pas d'ambition voilà
si on me donne une responsabilité
je serais très heureux de la mener à
terme
mais déjà avant tout c'est un travail
d'équipé et c'est ce que andré a réussi
à recréer sur le département
et voilà on également je dirais
l'énergie qui s'est créée autour de
l'énergie et eaux autour de pardon de
d'andré et de tous les candidats
c'est ce que les gens attendaient ben
voilà maintenant je dis on verra comment
ça se passera à suivre merci frédéric
brochot en direct du studio france 3
bourgogne du creusot autre réaction
concernant le passage à droite du
département de la saône-et-loire celle
du sénateur maire ump de mâcon
jean-patrick courtois
pour lui cette victoire de la droite va
lui simplifier la vie écoutez je suis
très heureux de voir que le département
bascule
et qu'à partir de demain nous aurons une
politique entre les collectivités
locales et le département
une politique qui sera une politique
consensuelle une politique ouverte une
politique de confiance et naturellement
avec mâcon puisque je vous rappelle que
depuis de longues années
mc on jamais pu avoir de dialogue avec
le conseil général de saône-et-loire et
je suis très heureux de savoir que
partir de demain j'aurais effectivement
une politique de respect mutuel mais en
même temps une politique consensuelle
jean patrick courtois sénateur maire ump
de mâcon
emmanuelle coint sur ce département de
la saône-et-loire vous partagez cette
analyse donc succès de la droite jean
patrick courtois disait que ça simplifie
la vie c'est aussi ce que vous attendez
de cette bascule enfin je pense
qu'effectivement ça crée des synergies
positives mais on voit bien que là où il
ya eu victoire c'est là où il y avait
limité et une équipe ensemble qui menait
le combat
donc je me réjouis pour andré et son
équipe
françois patriat donc c'est la saône et
loire c'est un peu le symbole de
l'affaiblissement de la gauche dans la
région elle est aussi affaibli en côte
d'or elle est aussi affaibli dans la
nièvre
elle est quasiment anéantie dans l'yonne
c'est inquiétant pour vous y compris sur
la grande région bourgogne franche comté
qui est maintenant la réalité parce
qu'il ya plus de départements direct un
recul de la gauche c'est clair pour la
saône et loire comme pour le doubs comme
pour le territoire de belfort le jura
c'était un peu une des chroniques de
défaite annoncée
on vous l'avait prédit on nous l'avait
dit on sans télé on sentait les
faiblesses le vrai hypothèque elle
portait sur les deux départements qui
sont restés à gauche parce que la nièvre
gagne sur le fil c'est bien vos la la
haute saône avec yves krattinger beau
combat mais c'était là qu'était vraiment
là aurait été la surprise pour le reste
je dis que c'est pas logique du tout
parce que quand j'entends dire le bilan
d' du président du conseil général
quand je vois comment elle s'est battue
pour la rcea con mais s'est battu pour
le center parcs
comment il a défendu les frais dossier
pour le haut débit je veux par
considérer que la politique du conseil
général de saône et loire est à remettre
en cause c'est une défaite nationale non
alors après il ya deux mots quand on a
une défaite il faut avoir deux vertus de
la lucidité et du courage mais moi je
crois que ses amis qui sont des faits
aujourd'hui
on sait de vertige ils doivent être
lucide mais j'entends des messages
contradictoires à la fois on nous dit
j'ai gagné parce que je suis en
proximité et d'autres vous disent ils
ont perdu à cause des méfaits du
gouvernement alors est ce que c'est la
proximité ou est ce que c'est le
gouvernement
non c'est un cocktail de tout bien
entendu mais dire que tel ou tel
candidat je pense qu'en côte-d'or mépris
volts ou bien à doutais qu'ils étaient
moins proximité que des candidats
potentiels que non nous un temps où
réclament de la proximité dans le même
temps 30% des bourguignons vote pour des
candidats sans visage qui ne connaissent
pas où est donc la proximité d'envoyer
l'avion la dre concept on a des concepts
tout fait moi je regrette pour la
saône-et-loire pour les les amis qu'ils
qui l'on disait qu'ils ont dirigé
aujourd'hui c'est un recul analysons le
et surtout pensons à l'avenir maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire demain
moi c'est ça la question j'aimerais
poser leur dû et vous qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire demain pour endiguer la
montée du front national et pour que la
gauche retrouve du crédit c'est ça la
question se pose pour demain bah
emmanuelle coint elle a senti le vent du
boulet d'ailleurs un vous avez souhaité
avec le royal mais c'est vrai je rejoins
ce que dit françois patriat s'est c'est
absolument incroyable parce qu'à la fois
on sent les gens veulent de la des élus
de proximité des gens qui les
comprennent qu'ils les entendent et qui
ceux qui sont dans un dialogue qui soit
dans un dialogue avec eux et
parallèlement à ça ils votent
massivement pour des gens qui n'ont
quasiment pas mis les pieds sur le
territoire qui ne sont pas allés les
rencontrer
c'est un vrai paradoxe est effectivement
il va falloir regarder ça avec avec
finesse pour les prochaines élections
céline maglica on entend beaucoup de
choses effectivement on entend la droite
dire les français veulent une autre
politique sous-entendent une politique
de droite en entrant une partie de la
gauche dire les français veulent une
autre politique vous entendu plus à
gauche
et puis en même temps les français ils
ont voté dans beaucoup d'endroits à
tiers d'entre eux partis au premier tour
pour le front national dont on sait que
sur les actions départementales il avait
à peu près pas de programme c'est quoi
votre sentiment vous c'est un mal être
ou c'est une vraie demande
les deux c'est à dire qu'à la fois on
est quand même dans une crise économique
qui est profond on a eu on a la gauche
est arrivé au pouvoir avec un bilan de
droite qui était très lourd à gérer ne
faut quand même pas l'oublier
après effectivement les gens quand on
est en porte à porte en proximité avec
eux ce qu'ils nous disent et qu'est ce
que vous pouvez faire pour nous qu est
ce que la politique peut encore faire
pour nous nos enfants ne trouvent pas de
travail on a tel était le problème
qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire pour
nous et je crois qu'effectivement il lui
c'est à nous de retrouver cette
confiance parce que au-delà des clivages
politiques moi ce que j'ai entendu dans
cette élection à travers à la fois
l'abstention très forte à la fois les
votes blancs les votes nuls dont on ne
parle jamais je crois qu'il faut en
parler parce que les gens qui se
déplacent pour aller mettre dans une
urne un vote blanc ou un vote nul
ils nous passent un message ils nous
disent quelque chose qu'est ce qu'ils
nous disent nous disent finalement la
politique on n'y croit plus on n'y croit
plus donc qu'est ce qu'on fait pour eux
eh bien il faut retrouver l'ancrage de
la politique il faut être en proximité
on l'a dit mais c'est quand même
important effectivement ses
contradicteurs les gens et qu'ils votent
pour le front national ce sont des
candidats inexistant et nous mêmes par
coller leurs affiches sur le deuxième
tournoi sur le canton de dijon 6 donc
inexistant et je crois que le message le
plus important que les électeurs nous
passent à travers l'abstention le vote
des extrêmes le vote blanc le vote nul
c'est on a besoin de re croire en la
politique
il faut donc renouveler nos pratiques
politiques et je crois pas en tant
qu'élus nous avons tous à nous
interroger là dessus comment faire pour
renouveler nos pratiques politiques et
pour retrouver cette confiance ne
poursuivra que la côte d'or à présent
une majorité renforcée
les résultats avec vous a besoin voyez
nuits saint georges le duo emmené par
hubert poullot l'emportent avec 234 voix
d'écart face au candidat de la gauche
affaibli dans les zones rurales
victoire également à genlis du tandem
ump divers droite devant le front
national est la droite gagne aussi à
brazey-en-plaine grâce au front
républicain le désistement des candidats
de gauche après le premier tour a
bénéficié à emmanuelle coint et gilles
delepau seul couac pour la majorité la
perte de talent le sortant gilbert menut
et battu une victoire surprise pour la
gauche ici en dépit de
vision la gauche il limite la casse dans
les cantons périphériques et souffre
notamment chenôve mais aussi l'on vit
avec christophe lucand et céline
tonneaux à noter que la gauche battue
dans les campagnes résiste bien dans les
cantons en dijonnais elle en gagne 4 sur
6 dont dijon 2 pour le duo milieu
qu'anders dijon trois cantons de la
toison d'or et de grésille avec hamid el
hassouni ou encore et elle est avec nous
dijon 6 où le tandem andré gervais
cécile maglica s'impose très largement
these licka nous avoir la carte la côte
d'or voyant sa nouvelle partition la
réalité le seul canton rural que la
gauche va concerner alors n'y a pas de
donner tout il est content bien
évidemment mais vous les retrouvez sur
notre site internet
évidemment on va s'intéresser au canton
de montbard avec la défaite du sortant
prg patrick molinoz zh et est revanche
pour l'aider laurence porte qui avait
perdu les cantonales en 2011
reportage à montbard hier soir signé
bintou sidibé et jean loup saint tin les
foules 11 11 a obtenu 15 mille deux cent
mille morts soit 52 3 bien vu l'a rendu
pour 583 voix séparent les deux
formations
le résultat est sans appel ce soir
contrairement en 2011 aucune
contestation de l'élection ne sera fait
leur ans porte candidate malheureuse des
dernières cantonales copiant sa revanche
après la ville de montbard le canton pas
su aussi à droite marc frot et laurence
porte deviennent les nouveaux
conseillers départementaux on
la même campagne au deuxième tour qu'au
premier proche des gens et nous on
mélange pas tout on est conseiller
départemental
on s'occupe des gens et on ne fait pas
de la politique politicienne et on ne
parle pas de forcément de paris si c'est
sur moissac a fait la différence
les gens veulent qu'on s'occupe d'eux et
qu'on soit n'est pas frimeur un tacle en
direction de patrick molinoz conseiller
général durant 13 ans et dont le mandat
ne sera pas renouvelé
le binôme qui forme avec ce mario
mongouachon n'a pas réussi à convaincre
les électeurs des candidats éliminés au
premier tour
visiblement l'essentiel les voix du
front national se sont reportés sur
madame porte sans doute la politique du
gouvernement est sanctionné ce soir et
puis ce redécoupage et cette réforme que
j'ai combattu voilà on voit que les
résultats attendus ou plutôt pas attendu
mais en tout cas craint donc là mais on
va continuer de travailler
on est conforté commune canton de
venarey
l'affrontement s'annonce est très serré
mais ici comme ailleurs en côte d'or la
droite au sort victorieuse de ces
élections et même une gauche unie n'aura
rien pu y faire à la verse encodeur donc
sur le talent canton de dijon 6 céline
maglica vous remportez ce canton avec
votre binôme et andré gervais al'inverse
de la tendance dans le département donc
ça veut dire que sur la ville sur
l'agglomération dijonnaise le parti
socialiste a beaucoup plus travaillé que
sur les autres secteurs ruraux du
département oh je sais pas si on veut
dire que les uns contre les autres ceux
qui travaillent plus ou moins je pense
qu'on peut pas dire les choses comme ça
on peut se réjouir en revanche
effectivement que dans l'agglomération
dijonnaise
la gauche reste bien ancré a fait un
vrai travail de terrain
il ya un ancrage quand même mis un
ancrage qui est là évidemment à travers
tous les élus nous on est
particulièrement satisfait de notre
score puisque ont fait le plus beau
score de côte-d'or
on en n'est pas peu fier et on remercie
tous ceux qui nous ont soutenus et
notamment et ce n'était pas le cas
partout le but
de droite éliminé au premier tour qui a
appelé à voter pas fait ce que j'allais
dire le binôme que formaient lionel
fourré avec sa colistière avec son
binôme et de manière républicaine a voté
pour nous contre le front national
on les a on les en remercier parce que
ça n'a pas été le cas partout
ça n'était pas la position de françois
sauvadet qui lui appelait au onu ni un
don qui a favorisé le front national ça
n'a pas été le cas des effectivement dû
du binôme républicain qui était qui
était face à nous on les en remercie et
puis je crois que c'est vraiment le
travail de terrain l'ancrage et puis on
avait une très très belle équipe
vraiment une très belle équipe très
dynamique avec plein de jeunes gens et
est plein de danseurs évitant aussi ils
ont aidé à faire cette belle campagne et
on est très satisfait un mot sur les
conséquences de leur a peut-être au
conseil général c'est la droite qui est
majoritaire bien sûr de départementale
est allé à l'école quoi c'est la mienne
c'est ma faute
il ya un vrai renouvellement il ya un
vrai rajeunissement il va y avoir un
vrai renouvellement alors bien sûr il y
aura la parité une féminisation mais
aussi beaucoup plus de conseillers
urbains et on va dire même de conseiller
socialiste que dans le groupe de gauche
pressée d'en haut au conseil général
départemental
est-ce qu'il va avoir des conséquences
alors il ya un vrai renouvellement mais
je crois que c'est une assemblée qui en
avait vraiment besoin
j'étais jusque là la plus jeune ce ne
sera pas le cas demain j'en suis ravi la
parité évidemment qu est une très belle
avancée une très belle victoire dans
notre pays et pour notre démocratie
et puis un renouvellement mais nous
posons pas les urbains en rond moi je
suis sur un canton qui est mixte qui est
urbain et rural je le défendrai toujours
et je suis conseillère départementale
les monts du sens je défendrai le
département de la côte d'or et vous
l'avez dit c'est vous qui avez obtenu le
meilleur score de la gauche dans le
département
ça vous donne des ailes est ce que vous
serez pas ce qu'on en parlait ces
derniers jours candidate à la présidence
du groupe de gauche
alors ça donne forcément une légitimité
j'étais déjà vice présidente de mon
groupe politique
oui je vais proposer ma candidature moi
je propose surtout quelque chose d'un
peu nouveau
ce que je propose qu'on soit en binôme
pour être à la tête de l'opposition
départementale je propose que ce soit un
homme et une femme parce que je crois
que le message de nos électeurs
aujourd'hui dans leur ensemble ça a été
de dire il faut renouveler une fois de
plus vos pratiques politiques mais pour
moi c'est un premier pas proposons non
pas une hégémonie et un seul homme ou
une seule femme
mais allons-y à 2 et dans ce cadre là je
suis candidate effectivement à la
présidence de mon groupe avec qui avec
un homme
je le sais pas encore lequel on en
discutera demain puisqu'on est en
réunion justement de manière
démocratique et est en totale
camaraderie en fraternité on en décidera
merci céline maglica nous allons vous
libérer en signalant d'ailleurs au
passage que la parité plus que respecté
ce midi sur ce plateau sur france 3
bourgogne
nagui qu'on va vous libérer pour laisser
la place à la 1ère chance qui va nous
rejoindre dans un instant nous en partir
pour talent autre illustration des
revers de la droite alan gilbert menut
le maire de la ville perd son siège
scrutin très serré inattendu et les
réactions étaient plutôt vives au moment
de l'annoncé des résultats officiels
comme ont constaté hier soir pauline
ringenbach et amélie des noms pascal
robin anne on revient pas il serait
devant à quelques voix près tout se joue
dans un mouchoir de poche
le suspense reste entier jusqu'à ce que
le candidat ump sortant gilbert menut
viennent annoncer lui même
officiellement sa défaite
3500 le à ferreira 2147 et sont et
burnhaupt d'un jacques robin à 3770 voix
une défaite qui semble difficile à
encaisser pour le maire de talant
l'ambiance n'est pas au beau fixe entre
les deux parties
la poignée de main est à peine cordiale
les voix du candidat de droite éliminé
au premier tour se sont répartis entre
les trois binômes restreindre cette
élection se joue donc à 2% des suffrages
en faveur du parti socialiste je pense
que la différence c'est pour notre
représentativité de la liste en fait on
avait une élue de la ville
un élu rural et je pense que ça a
réellement joué et les gens se sont
rendu compte que vraiment on
représentait l'ensemble du canton
197 voix d'écart seulement entre le
conseiller sortant de la vallée de
l'ouche et celui de la commune de talent
un résultat très serré
à l'image d'un canton tiraillé entre
zones urbaines et ruralité
voilà pour le canton donc de talent en
côte-d'or réaction emmanuelle coint pour
l'été de la division du premier tour on
savait qu'elle est un binôme me sens
bien je me doute non effectivement on
voit bien que là où on part désunie il
n'y a pas de victoire mais on l'a vu
aussi sur des cantons on parlait tout à
l'heure de la saône et loire deux
défaites quand il ya désunion quelle
qu'en soit la famille politique
eh bien il ya l'échec de cette famille
politique au bout et c'est l'union qui
fait la victoire c'est indéniable il y
avait aussi la suite quand même des
élections sénatoriales
oui dans ses engagements une élection a
toujours la suite d'une autre mais là il
ya vraiment la suite des élections
sénatoriales ans que j'avais déjà dit
lâche la chaudrée - premiers propos bien
sûr cette division est le fruit des
sénatoriales c'est regrettable savez en
politique on y on pardonne tout nous dit
rien avec un rejet donc deux pour être
clair de de la candidature du maire de
talant je pense que vous savez quand il
y a une division premier tour il sort
laisse toujours des traces dans
l'électorat et je ne sais pas si c'est
gilbert qui a été sanctionnée par
rapport à sa candidature aux
sénatoriales où les traces du premier
tour le canton de brazey-en-plaine qui
englobe les villes de seurre et de saint
jean donne également ses votre canton là
vous avez été élu dans un contexte
particulier rappelons le avec ce front
républicain le plus long voilà vous
aviez cette peur que le front national
puisse prendre un canton en côte-d'or a
bien sûr mais sûr puisque vous même vous
le disiez que s'il ya un canton qui
devait tomber c'était celui-là entre les
mains du front national et au delà de
nos destins personnels vous imaginez ce
que cela veut dire pour un pour un
territoire pour les élus les habitants
du territoire
si vous voyez pas les candidats pendant
la campagne vous imaginez une fois
qu'ils sont élus s'ils vont être sur le
terrain
donc ça avait des conséquences
absolument dramatiques pour notre
territoire et je verrai autres
territoires c'est à dire qu'est ce que
le front national était plus en capacité
de l'emporter parce que dans ces zones
rurales une petite ville il ya
aujourd'hui une situation pour beaucoup
de gens qui est extrêmement difficile
mais nous avons un difficile peut-être
que sur l'agglomération dijonnaise
mais nous avons un taux de chômage
extrêmement élevé vous le savez que ce
soit sur la commune de saint gengoux
deux soeurs nous sommes au delà des dd
moyenne
nationale donc ce sont des cantons et en
face est un canton pardon extrêmement
éprouvée est indéniablement bal cd vote
aussi de dourges est de ras-le-bol en
disant vous êtes impuissant on a tout
essayé on va essayer l'autre côté est ce
qu'il faut quand même voir que
saint-jean enfin l'ancien canton de
saint jean a été un canton
historiquement à gauche
donc on voit bien là aussi
l'hétérogénéité de l'électorat frontiste
qui ce ne sont pas que des déçus de la
droite ce sont aussi des déçus de la
gauche
donc c'est un terrain assez compliqué
emmanuelle coint je propose d'écouter
une réaction celle de françois rebsamen
et se réjouit de votre élection ou
plutôt il salue la position du parti
socialiste te respecte le front
républicain
les partis républicains doivent se
ressaisir la gauche a donné l'exemple
dans ce département
elle a retiré sans hésiter son candidat
sur le canton de seurre pour permettre
l'élection de madame coin j'en suis très
heureux je suis toujours très heureux
quand un républicain bas quelqu'un qui
est du front national voilà je voulais
le dire clairement ici j'espère que ça
sera pareil à droite j'ai quelques
craintes de ce côté là les craintes de
france mais ça peut paraître cocasse
parce que vous fait partie du groupe et
vous êtes la leader de l'opposition au
conseil régional françois patriat vous
allez soutenu aussi la candidature de
madame coin sur ce avoir été le premier
le dire sur ce plateau est justement
dimanche dernier à 8h à 20h donc j'ai
dit j'ai souhaité alors est ce que ça ne
donne pas aussi raison au front national
quand il parle du mps est ce que ça ne
risque pas de troubler les électeurs qui
secoue leur dit aux électeurs à ce
propos je dis aux électeurs aujourd'hui
que faut quand même pas se tromper ni de
condamne d'idéal
ja je me pose mal en quoi elle ma
principale opposante au conseil régional
il n'empêche qu'il y ait un respect
mutuel et j'entends de leurs positions
des propositions que j'écoute que je
prends même parfois avec qui je peux
dialoguer parce que sur la laïcité parce
que sur l'immigration parce que sur le
social
nous partageons des valeurs qui nous
sont communes même si les voix ne sont
pas communes alors que quand j'entends
quand j'entends les élus du front
national au conseil régional et que
j'entends je veux dire leur proposition
leur position sur l'europe sur l'euro
sur le sûr aujourd'hui le social sur la
santé eh ben je suis abasourdi des
propositions que je voudrais quand en
leurs électeurs aujourd'hui mais je vous
dis la solution elle est sans doute à
trouver pour demain dont des vraies
réformes pour notre pays on ne luttera
pas le front national contre x seul par
des slogans et par des a priori on
réussira contre le front national qui
nous sommes capables de faire évoluer
les choses dans un sens ce qu'attendent
les français au delà du mou frimeur
qu'elle est toute à l'heure évoqué est
donc un candidat élu parce que c'est les
électeurs attendent de quoi des
candidats de la probité de la
transparence de leur proximité du
travail il me semble pas que ni patrick
molinoz denis me suis pris vols étaient
des gens qu'il était papa travailleurs
et pas proche
donc c'est pas ça la vraie réalité c'est
on a ils ont voté olivier jean ont voté
sur un ressenti nationale pour moi je
pense que demain il faut vraiment
transformer ce pays qui aujourd'hui
souhaite la réforme mais ne l'avait pas
veut la réforme ne la pratique pas et
que dès qu'on veut faire les vraies
réformes passées vraiment la 6ème
république
je ne crois aujourd'hui il faut
aujourd'hui que nous que nous puissions
avancer seul et dans le domaine social
dans le domaine des collectivités qu'on
fasse une vraie réussite est loin
d'autres qui changent les choses demain
c'est cela que nous pourrons demain et
ça ça veut dire qu'il faut se parler
entre la droite et la gauche
il faut se parler entre la droite et la
gauche pour obtenir des majorités de
circonstance qui font avancer le pays
sur la voie de la réforme l'énergie on
nous avait rejoints sur ce plateau
vous étiez vous même avec ludovic
rochette candidat sur le canton de dijon
iv dans une autre situation que ce qu'on
vient d'évoquer sur braz et puisque dans
votre canton le front national n'a pas
été qualifiée pour le deuxième tour il y
avait un peu plus de 20% des voix pour
le front national
voulant porter ce qui se disait hier sur
les plateaux de télé dans les médias et
avec les candidats s'étaient qu'une part
importante du vote front national du
premier tour vous avez profité est ce
que c'est votre analyse aussi alors
c'est pas tout à fait mon analyse
bien évidemment il ya eu un retour
naturel pourquoi parce que les gens qui
ont voté front national au premier tour
n'était pas des gens qui sont ancrées
dans ce front national mais des gens qui
ont des valeurs de droite républicaine
qui avait fait un vote sanction et qui
naturellement ce revenu vers nous et
aussi on a capitalisé sur la
mobilisation de notre électorat qui
s'étaient pas déplacés au premier tour
et qui est venu massivement au deuxième
tour quel regard vous portez pardon sur
braz et où là la théorie du front
républicain a été mise en application
avec candidat de gauche qui se retire il
avait mille huit cents voix mais
emmanuel quoi vous progressez 2004 sans
voix je crois entre le premier et le
deuxième tour donc un report qui semble
à peu près peu près automatique les gens
qui sont pas retourner voter oui ça
c'est beaucoup plus mais quand même
envole x d'accord avec vous mais
néanmoins en volume on voit qu'on voit
une dynamique on est d'accord
quel regard vous portez là dessus
écoutez moi je me félicite que moi je
suis une jeune élue entre guillemets je
me félicite qu'on réponde enfin aux
aspirations des français qui en ont un
véritable ras-le-bol de ces clivages
politiques qui sont stériles qui eux ne
leur rapporte rien et je me félicite qu
en cas de difficulté on sache se parler
et trouver les solutions concrètes
ensemble il est temps alors vous disiez
que les gens premier tour voter en
partie pour le pour le front national
par rejet sans doute du gouvernement 2
et de leurs difficultés à vivre
finalement qu'est ce que doit faire un
nouvelle majorité à la majorité
renouvelée du conseil général maintenant
que ça change tout simplement je pense
que la majorité du conseil général
d'être en capacité d'entendre et surtout
de proposer proposé pour son territoire
évidemment de l'emploi parce que je
pense que les français attendent
aujourd'hui beaucoup de ça de l'emploi
de limiter les impôts parce que quand on
voit des retraités qui ont leurs impôts
multiples par deux en deux ans il ya un
moment où ça doit s'arrêter
et puis ils attendent qu'on agisse au
quotidien pour eux les compétences du
conseil départemental seront des
compétences sutout sociétales comme
précédemment le conseil général on
continuera cette politique d'action
sociale au profit de ceux qui en ont
besoin qu'ils sont fragiles mais il faut
que cette aide aille vraiment ceux qui
n'ont vraiment besoin on continue notre
tour d'horizon avec l yonne à présent où
là aussi la droite est présente et
renforcé après son deuxième tour des
élections départementales exemple à à
pont-sur-yonne où le front national
était en tête au premier tour un duel
pour ce deuxième tour le fn ne
l'emportent pas vous le voyez sur ses
résultats donc la droite a gagné hier
soir
reportage de basis djaouti et cédric le
poitevin à pont-sur-yonne
différents o'toole a recueilli 2059 bois
et la liste de grégory dorte et de
dominique sino 2519 voix ouais les
résultats athènes proclamer les premiers
mots de grégory dorte tout nouveau
conseil de droite et lui vaut au binôme
de gauche présente dans la salle
son désistement entre les deux tours
pour faire barrage au fn a été décisif
sambi un homme de gauche je pense pas
qu'on aura gagné enfin ça aurait été
beaucoup plus serré donc je salue encore
une fois le sens des responsabilités
2010 gouro et de son binôme dont
françoise martin c'est un geste d'une
grande élégance un sens aigu des
responsabilités
donc chapeau les grandes perdantes donc
les candidats front national battu de
plus de 400 voix il fut si l'alliance
ump s il est élu grâce au désistement
dont de ningbo il eu grâce à la gauche
les élus grâce au pass socialistes y ait
qu'un seul vainqueur ce soir c'est
manuel valls hollande et manuel valls
qui a ordonné à 2000 bourreau de tester
et c'est
dominique bourreau qui apporte la
victoire à grégory dorte le front
républicain donc fonctionner sur le
canton de pause sur yonne et la gauche
s'en félicite
les voix se sont portées sur le candidat
de droite je dors tu es sur son île son
binôme madame sino c'est ce que nous
avions appelée à faire en début de
semaine faire barrage au front national
et faire triompher la démocratie
une victoire du binôme de droite après
le désistement de la gauche le scénario
était presque écrite d'un ans mais avec
seulement près de 400 voix d'écart le
front national continue sa percée dans
le nord de l'yonne et donne déjà rendez
vous aux prochaines élections et voyons
d'autres d'autres résultats dans l'yonne
elsa où la droite est donc confortée
mais la gauche perd gros notamment sur
les cantons d'auxerre 3 cantons sur
quatre sont désormais détenues par la
droite et c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
le député ump guillaume larrivé qui
étend son influence a décidément rude
soirée pour la gauche dans l'yonne même
dans son bastion d'avalon où elle était
engagée dans une triangulaire elles
chutent face à la droite
c'était tangent rejoignit tombe dans
l'escarcelle de la gauche c'est une
suite logique des municipales et dans ce
canton on peut dire que le front
républicain a fonctionné à noter enfin
que l'yonne en rate également aura
également pardonnez moi les deux seuls
élus front national de la région à
villeneuve sur yonne le duo frontiste a
été élu avec 200 voix d'avancé
précisons que nous avons sauté donne la
parole aux candidats du front national à
ce binôme élu et que nous avons des
difficultés à les joindre
comme c'était le cas d'ailleurs pour la
cour de la campagne lorsque nous avons
voulu réaliser des reportages et joindre
ses candidats front national certains
parlaient de candidats fantômes
s'envisage comme leurs opposants
pouvaient dire difficile de les joindre
en tout cas on suppose qu'ils siégeront
pourra voir s'il sera effectivement au
conseil départemental nous serrons cela
la bataille et s'engage maintenant dans
l'yonne à droite pour la présidence du
département vous le savez ce sera jeudi
le vote pour le président avec un
troisième tour déjà dans tous les
esprits dès hier soir lors de l'annoncé
des résultats du deuxième tour déjà deux
candidats à droite dans l'yonne le
sortant udi andré villiers et le
sénateur et conseiller départemental ump
jean baptiste lemoyne reportage de
nathalie d'affaires et
sitôt les résultats connus la bataille
pour le perchoir va son plein hier soir
un affrontement par caméra interposée en
direct sur notre antenne
le premier à dégainer l'ump jean
baptiste lemoyne
il annonce officiellement sa candidature
et en profite pour égratigner le bilan
du président sortant andré villiers le
but c'est de faire remonter un peu le
département de l'yonne dans dans le haut
du tableau
1 parce que vous savez nous on a là gît
à auxerre qui est en ligue 2 on en
revient qui monte en ligue 1 et dans le
département de l'yonne on l'a vu un peu
trop souvent dans les bas de tableau
dans les classements sur les
départements et nous on a envie de faire
bouger ça on a envie d'être très
volontariste parce qu'encore une fois il
ya une attente ya un cri de désespoir
qui a été émis par par l'électorat au
premier tour 1 le président sortant udi
andré villiers ne tarde pas à riposter
il fustige le manque d'expérience et de
connaissance du terrain de son jeune
adversaire
aujourd'hui nos concitoyens veulent des
gens qui soient impliqués au quotidien
dans le terrain savez lorsqu'on déclare
par exemple que à l'occasion de la
campagne électorale on découvre des
situations difficiles que les artisans
que les agriculteurs qu'un grand nombre
de ménages sont à la peine à cause de la
crise et à cause de décisions qui ne
sont pas prises au niveau national
moi j'ai pas besoin de faire campagne
pour cela puisque je vis au milieu des
gens et je sais tout ça au quotidien
pour arbitrer cette lutte interne
un autre homme fort de la droite dans
l'yonne le député ump guillaume larrivé
faim de jouer les casques bleus
mais son soutien à andré villiers
transparaît assez nettement
il faut que le sénateur lemoine prix du
président villiers trouve la manière de
s'organiser pour faire du bon travail
maintenant je travaille depuis des
années avec andré villiers et je
souhaite pouvoir continuer à travailler
avec andré vie en filigrane de tout cela
c'est bien la suprématie à droite pour
la décennie à venir qui se joue entre
les deux jeunes parlementaires ump
guillaume larrivé et jean-baptiste
lemoyne la nièvre à présent c'est
désormais le seul département
bourguignon à gauche hier soir la nièvre
a résisté à la poussée de l'ump et du
front national en remportant dix cantons
sur dix est une victoire sur le film
pour le ps et ses sympathisants
avec 80 voix d' avance régis guillon et
cécile claveau respect respect tu sais
ça patrice joly peut avoir le sourire
son département résiste et reste en rose
comme depuis 60 ans une victoire pour le
ps et pour des sympathisants issus du
terrain alors que par le passé nous
avions essentiellement des candidats
issus du parti chez liszt là la nouvelle
rue des configurations au découpage
nouveau redécoupage des cantons nous a
conduits à faire appel à des gens qui
avaient une autre sensibilité politique
de gauche qu'ils reconnaissaient dans
nos valeurs et qui ont accepté de
rentrer en compétition avec nous
l'assemblée départementale compte
désormais vingt conseillers de gauche
disent de droite et 4 sans étiquette
pour le ps nièvre une victoire oui mais
sur le fil
patrice joly en tire les conséquences on
se doit d'être dans un département comme
le nôtre dans une démarche de
rassemblement
nous sommes là pour travailler ensemble
et je voudrais leur dire aujourd'hui
rassemblement de l'ensemble de ceux qui
peuvent être utiles au développement de
l'agglomération de la ville de nevers et
de l'ensemble du territoire
départemental
c'est l'appel que je lance aujourd'hui
pourquoi pas se réunir bien entendu
essayé de travailler ensemble sur des
projets sur d'autres orientations
si ça peut améliorer les choses nous
sommes partants nous sommes prêts à
collaborer pour le bien-être du
département évidemment pour faire gagner
la nièvre puisque ça notre objectif
la nièvre un bout du monde et surtout ce
matin un îlot rose entouré par des
départements qui ont eu ou sont restés
ou ont viré en bleu et voyons justement
avec vous à d'autres résultats pour ce
département de la nièvre
alors vous l'avez dit le département
reste à gauche la nouvelle assemblée
comptera désormais 20 conseillers de
gauche disent de droite et 4 sans
étiquette
patrice joly réélu à château chinon peut
être satisfait la gauche qui conserve la
plupart de ses bastions elle s'impose à
fourchambault elles l'emportent
également dans le canton de 2,6 en
revanche dans le nord un canton lui
échappe cosne sur loire qui passe à
droite
et c'est grâce à une large victoire du
tandem ump divers droite 61% des
suffrages à noter l'entrée dans
l'assemblée départementale 2
binôme de denis thuriau maire de nevers
le mouvement nièvre à venir gagner à
9h04 courte victoire aussi à
varennes-vauzelles avec 44 voix d'écart
terminons enfin avec une victoire à
l'arraché victoire sur le fil celle de
socialistes fabien bazin qui retrouve
son fauteuil à corbigny et ça s'est joué
de très peu seulement 22 voix d' avance
fabien bazin nous attend direct de
nevers bonjour fabien bazin
on l'a dit cette victoire d'une courte
tête s'est pas passé loin et ont en
effet pas passé loin vous avez bien lu
les chiffres voilà bon c'est la réalité
de cette cette élection qui était un peu
troublé parce que je crois que les
territoires très élargi la formule
d'aidé quadrino mme plus que des plus
que des binômes à semer probablement le
trouble dans dans l'électorat il ya une
majorité quand même qui est affaibli
finalement au conseil général au conseil
départemental c'est à mon tour de faire
au conseil départemental de l'année mais
toujours uni derrière son président
avait clairement oui je crois qu'il ya
une très belle équipe
encore une fois le lait quadrino mme
plus que les binômes ça a porté à la
fois delà de la fraîcheur du renouveau
de nouveaux visages avec des élus
expérimenté ça va être un vrai cocktail
et je pense que la majorité
départementale toujours avec son esprit
d'ouverture c'est comme ça qu'on
travaille dans l'annuaire doit faire du
bon travail avec ces nouvelles équipes
fabien bazin on sait que votre canton
étaient visés par le front national
clairement en particulier sur les zones
rurales
le front national est allé au premier
tour il a perdu des voix entre le
premier et deuxième tours
alors comment vous expliquer ce
phénomène et vous quel a été votre ligne
de conduite entre les deux tours contre
le front national en particulier à
écouter je crois qu'on était de toute
façon sur leurs quatre candidatures au
premier tour 3 ou seconde triangulaire
il y avait chacun était dans sa famille
dans dans dans ses idées personne n'en a
finalement trop dévier le sujet encore
c'est un sujet national c'est à dire que
les politiques publiques de soutien à la
ruralité sont à sont à construire les
départements les régions font beaucoup
certes mais il nous manque une grande
loi sur la sur la ruralité qui
permettrait à nos concitoyens de
finalement de s'y retrouver ce fameux
sentiment d'abandon qu'on a largement
commenté ces dernières années c'est une
réalité qui est vécue sur le terrain
alors on peut faire des choses on n'en
fait d'ailleurs on a des résultats
concrets mais c'est difficile pour les
territoires ruraux d'intégrer ce moment
particulier de l'histoire ce changement
de civilisation où on passe d'un exode
rural qui a duré un siècle et demi a
aujourd'hui l'exode urbain et il faut
qu'on arrive à résoudre la quadrature du
cercle
ça passe par la mise en oeuvre de
politiques publiques nationales d'une
loi de la république sur le sujet ça a
été travaillé avec le bouclier rural
avec les nouvelles ruralités plus
récemment ou encore avec cette idée
qu'il n'a pas nous appartient d'inventer
les villages du futur pour nos petites
villes et nos villages
fabien bazin on connaît votre proximité
avec le député dit frondeurs christian
paul quelle leçon aujourd'hui le
gouvernement doit-il tirer de cette
défaite nationale ah bah écoutez il ya
clairement aujourd'hui des propositions
qui sont sur la table
il ya un nouveau contrat de majorité qui
est qui est proposé il faut rentrer dans
cette logique de
discussion on va pas continuer à perdre
des élections de manière sempiternel
jusqu'à jusqu'à 2017 pour connaître
évidemment l'apothéose à ce moment là il
est encore temps de réussir le
quinquennat ça passe par un travail
justement d'ecoute de respect du du
parlement comme d'ailleurs sur le
terrain sur les mêmes sujets il faut
écouter nos concitoyens travailler avec
eux construire avec que ces politiques
publiques
les frondeurs aujourd'hui c'est rien
d'autre que c'est comme cela mais c'est
tout cela merci fabien bazin en direct
de nos studios france 3 bourgogne à
nevers dans la soirée électorale hier
sur france 3 il ya eu une part et demi
les temps forts l'appel de nicholas ray
à un changement de politique qui a
précisément de la gauche après la
défaite de son clan politique et du
gouvernement écouter nicolas serait élu
à joigny dans l'yonne hier le
gouvernement est aujourd'hui dans
l'échec
donc soit les résultats arrivent
désormais très rapidement soit il va
falloir dare-dare trouver une nouvelle
orientation à la politique
gouvernementale
parce que moi j'ai fait du porte à porte
pendant toute ma campagne j'ai vu des
gens qui me disaient on adore le boulot
vous faites à joigny mais au nom de ce
que vous représentez
on ne votera pas pour vous est ce que je
représente mois dans l'yonne c'était le
parti socialiste qui est aujourd'hui au
gouvernement
donc j'ai entendu le message voilà j'ai
entendu le message et et je vais je vais
le transmettre et vous savez ce que là
les gens m'ont dit aussi ils m'ont dit
la droite a échoué et la gauche a trahi
voilà ce que moi j'ai entendu durant
tous ces mois de campagne françois
patriat ce que vous avez entendu vous
hostiles à bouger pas même d'abord j'ai
celui la brillante élection de nicolas
soret caveau droite aujourd'hui c'est le
fruit de son implantation de son travail
c'est vrai il a un tout petit mot aussi
sur la proximité
j'avais tout le monde réclame de la
proximité et un électeur sur deux n'a
pas voté
la première proximité d'aller voter
avant de donner des leçons de proximité
que les électrices et des électeurs ne
soient eux mêmes
je partage pas l'analyse de nicolas en
substance que on dit le gouvernement a
trahi à treilles quoi la treille qui les
engagements pris pendant la campagne sur
l'essentiel sont tenues aujourd'hui que
tu as gouvernement il essaye de
redresser les comptes de la nation
et l'essai depuis de créer les
conditions du développement économique
pour demain je viens d'aller faire une
matinée avec emmanuel macron abu
initiateurs données remarquable réunion
où la place de l'innovation ou la place
des nouveaux financements ou la plage du
portel c'est la reconquête c'est la
relocalisation près ce que fait ce
gouvernement
alors si demain le gouvernement reprend
le chemin d'écouter les frondeurs pour
des raisons de congrès du ps on va je
pense
écoutez les frondeurs continuer comme on
fait aujourd'hui a essayé de faire à la
fois du talon-pointe du talon-pointe je
pense que non ce gouvernement doit être
courageux mener les réformes qu'il a
entreprises sur la valériane et jusqu'au
bout les mener jusqu'au bout
et quitte à perdre les élections le
problème n'est pas là aujourd'hui c'est
savoir quel est l'intérêt de la france
et des français
mais si celui là aujourd'hui françois
patriat s'est pas plus de gauche qu'on
demande et les français puisque c'est la
droite qui a gagné les élections mais il
devance les français ils ont demandé
plus de droite c'est une vision un peu
simpliste
regardez comme tel mais qu'elle n'est
pas aussi sûr pas aussi simpliste que de
demander plus de gauche
moi je pense que surtout il faut pas
oublier les raisons de la victoire en
2012 de françois hollande
est ce que c'est parce que les français
adhèrent à son programme
ou at il été élu simplement parce qu'on
était aux tss tout sauf sarko donc les
revenus donc ça laisse de parts marché
c'est un autre débat on en reparlera non
mais je parle de 2012
donc je parle pas de doute aujourd'hui
je dis simplement que je ne suis pas sûr
que la victoire de 2012 de françois
hollande a été jusqu'à était motivée par
une adhésion complet pleine et entière
nous projet voilà un rejet en dix ans la
droite échoue donc puisqu'on était quand
même
tout le monde le précédent mandat ça a
été 50 crise est donc là des gens ont
cru que ça allait aller mieux puisqu'on
leur a expliqué à gauche on a parfois
des divergences avec le président sur ce
sujet mais on a expliqué que c'était la
faute à la droite si ça allait si mal en
france c'est en tout cas il va falloir
donc vous êtes en train de nous rejouer
le duo vous je veux qu'on sait régional
cadets
réussi il aurait été réélu c'est la
patera lui c'est parce qu'il a échoué on
dit aujourd'hui que la gauche perde
parce qu'elle échoue mais françois
patriat donc à l'issue de ces élections
vous l'avez dit vous-même tout à l'heure
si département à droite sur la bourgogne
et franche-comté deux départements la
logique à savoir peut-être votre
situation plus compliquée vous êtes
candidat vous même ma situation c'est
une question qu'on me pose aujourd'hui
tous les chaouis il ya eu ce qu'ils
baptisent ayez acheté d'un seul coup
donc il ya même ceux qui me disait il ya
tout ce qu'il fallait tourner la page
que j'avais été là très longtemps que
j'avais réussi beaucoup de choses mais
qu'il était temps et même aujourd'hui
vont me dire exactement français
brillaient forestier à tout prix parce
que je ne suis pas le sauveur de la
bourgogne et je vais prendre ma décision
est l'analyse des résultats au rapport
des forces en présence à la possibilité
demain d'avoir accès sur la politique
que moi je souhaite mener aux côtés de
gouvernement aujourd'hui un tout à
l'heure j'ai dit emmanuel macron combien
dans le système de réforme économique
aujourd'hui j'étais sur sa ligne on va
voir si tout cela peu sage demain faire
une réelle ligne positive
j'ai encore un mois j'ai encore un mois
maintenant un mois vous aurez l'art et
président du fai s'est déjà lancée vous
axez il ya le risque du conflit conflit
parce que là il voyait il y aura un vote
démocratique pour les candidats qui a
sans doute marie-guite dufay
il peut ya voir françois patriat mais
peut y en avoir d'autres aussi mon cul
ras savez la première fois où j'ai gagné
la région
il y avait eu l'affrontement avec
christian paul souvenez-vous à l'époque
qui s'étaient soldés par un écart marne
et vous très bien fait alors emmanuel
macron est en visite ou le disait
aujourd'hui en bourgogne
il a évoqué justement ces rumeurs qui le
donnaient parachuté en bourgogne écouter
ce que dit emmanuel macron la
responsabilité n'est pas aujourd'hui de
m'intéresser à mon destin particulier
pour telle ou telle élection
tant soutenu par françois rebsamen de
plus te colle d'or ça serait bien mais
il ya des grands dirigeants régionaux
j'étais avec françois patriat ce matin
françois rebsamen est un ami il a
lui-même une charge importante au sein
du gouvernement mais ça n'est pas ma
priorité du moment et je ne serai pas
tête de liste à quelques régional que ce
soit je préfère il faut vous dire des
choses tout de go je peux vous le dire
parce que je crois que nos concitoyens
attendent de leurs décideurs politiques
autre chose que l'ambition politique
pour eux mêmes
le ministre de l'économie en déplacement
pour la semaine des as nous reviendrons
ce soir position il voulait sa place il
veut pas vous faire dont il a confié que
vous avez envie d'y aller j'en ai parlé
avec lui aussi ce matin je lui ai dit
que je serais très honoré de voir que
demain ils puissent y être conduits à la
région il a donné sa réponse
et après tout il se consacre à sa tâche
il ne se mêle pas de la bataille
politique aujourd'hui de la bataille
électorale
c'est plutôt noble de sa part respectons
la raquette bien alors il y aura
bataille aussi à droite
j'améliore des cache pas ses ambitions
pour la mairie
je comptais france ce serait des non
plus donc été on va déjà d'orienne
derrière françois sauvadet au départ
derrière l'année derrière françois
sauvadet se fera comme conséquences
derrière lui si pour les élections
régionales
écoutez je ne peux pas parler ou nous
les autres je ne peux vous parler qu'en
mon nom à moi et moi je trouve que c'est
un très bon président qui est très loyal
envers l'ump savez au département comme
à la région
on ne sait plus qui est quoi dans nos
groupes parce qu'on travaille ensemble
et on ne gagnera la région bourgogne
franche comté qu'ensemble non mais je
veux dire qu'ensemble se moquera merci
mais non merci françois patriat streamer
chance d'être venu au semis france 3
bourgogne retrouvez plus d'infos sur
notre site internet bien sûr on se
retrouve également ce soir pour le 19/20
largement consacrée aux élections
départementales tout de suite votre
série 1 cas pour deux ans à un fauteuil
pour deux à tout à l'heure pour le 19/20
en bourgogne
bon après midi sur france 3